cette année changement radical les
municipales intéressent la France
entière nous allons au cours des 45
minutes de ce débat essayer de voir
clair Gérard Colom le candidat de la
majorité de l'union de la gauche est le
plus jeune 35 ans il est très actif il
veut se faire un prénom et il s'appuie
sur la politique du gouvernement pour
l'emploi l'urbanisme les personnes âées
les gagnants ou là il y a des Haas ah
oui avec TR femmes ah oui son analyse
est historique Lyon n'aime pas s'opposer
pouvoir central et la ville dans le
passé a déjà eu des mes
socialistes estce que vous avez fait les
sondages la bataille qui est
actuellement en cours entre les deux
listes de droite renforce nos chances et
peut-être que la de gauche si elle fait
le plein de son capital de voie peut
gagner et créer la surprise sur Lyon